hello everyone my name is Johan I'd like
to talk about webassembly today and
specifically how you can put webassembly
in your web app in and I mean kind of
real world web assembly in your real
world web app although my webs gonna be
a demo one but anyway so I'm part Fox
developer at Mozilla I work in the
security engineering team I don't really
work on web assembly but I am a big
enthusiast and I follow it closely
last year I was here and talked about
web assembly - and I talked about the
web assembly text format and the web
simply binary format and how the two
like are related to each other and what
we did this is so this is a lot of code
you don't have to take it all in but
what we did was we looked at the like we
hand wrote some Cup some custom wasm
code that added two numbers and you can
see on the left hand side and then we
included it in our JavaScript app with
this very boilerplate code here and it
also has some logging in there so I just
find a copy pasted exactly the code that
we used back then and I totally
understood when a lot of you came to me
and also during the talk asked so this
is not really ready for production usage
right and it's true it wasn't there was
so back then you could I think it was a
point where you could already compile it
with a rust compiler for example if you
were if you wanted to use rust which
which also worked kind of okay so you
had to do the same kind of fetch e
webassembly api boilerplate and
satiation and then you have the same
limitations that you had with a web
assembly text code - so these
limitations are pretty gray if you can
only pass in numbers to like pass back
and forth numbers between web assembly
MJS and all other communication needs to
go through like shared memory buffers
like a big heap that has just I'd erase
in it well that you can allocate by the
radar but byte arrays on it and that is
very inconvenient and a lot of you said
that last time and I said
last time too so a year later we're here
and we have a new cool tool which is
called wasn't vine gem it's by my
amazing colleagues colleague Alex and he
wrote this tool to enable this sort of
higher level interactions between wazzle
and Jas that we didn't have previously
and what it does it automatically
generates the sort of Jas glue and it
only works in rust for now which is why
I'm going to do the demo that I'm going
to do soon and rust and this talk is
literally going to be 90% me demoing how
this Tool Works inviting setup for it so
I hope you are hearing for that yeah a
couple things you will need or we will
need for this and what I mean when I you
know in the first slide wrote from
scratch I mean you know from scratch we
don't I don't expect you to have well
although the rust knowledge would be
good but like no you should have a UNIX
computer that's kind of all and these
are the things you need to install them
and these should work out of the box and
then you're set right you can do it on
your developer machine you can integrate
the stuff into your existing project
like this and there is no extra magic
required if you don't have a UNIX
machine if you if you don't have the
time to download all the stuff from from
the conference Wi-Fi there's a really
cool web app which just launched it's
written by my awesome buddy colleagues
Michael and Yuri and it's it's amazing
it's called webassembly
studio and it allows you to run all this
code like the Jas part and the HTML and
the rust or C++ or C or just plain wasum
inside a web IDE and I absolutely
recommend you to check it out it's it's
really amazing and it gets you started
with wow them quite quickly it's an
online IDE so I wouldn't I guess you
can't use it for for a real word use
like production usage but it's really
cool to play around with so now I'm
gonna switch to my mic like terminal to
do a live demo here the requirements for
us we're gonna do a small web app that
computes a cryptographic hash of a
string like shop secure hash algorithm
and I already did the front end in j/s
and it has an index HTML file and an app
J's file it's not is not using any
complex Spangler's or frameworks or
whatever but that's not the point you
could as you will see you could still
integrate it if you
using complex stuff the point is that we
do the hash computation in wasm and in
rust in this case because rust has nice
compile-time checkers and because russ
orgasm tends to be faster than it is so
we just want to do it for the sake of it
let's switch to can everyone see this
I'm gonna enlarge people in the back if
you cannot see the code on the left hand
side please scream larger or something
fine cool perfect thank you so this is
our setup we have my address on the left
hand side my terminal is on the right
hand side and here we have two files in
my folder once called app dot J's and
once called index dot HTML index dot
HTML is you see I didn't really spend a
lot of time on the front end in the
exception is very simple it has an input
field it has a button and it has a
script tag and when you go to the script
we have we're getting the input we have
the button which we're getting and then
one click on the button we alert the
value of the input but there's a to-do
can we please hatch this which is what
we're going to do now using rust so how
do we start off if you want to start off
creating any Russ project and we will
have to create a small rust library for
this you use cargo cargo is the build
tool for rust and this is pretty cool
you can basically use cargo to create a
new rust project but if you want to use
the you know the rust code in your
project and your own big app or whatever
you could create the library basically
wherever you like and whichever
directory like because in the end
obviously it generates some has an
output and then you could just use your
whatever setup you have your gulp file
you make files your web pack or whatever
to move it to the right position so I'm
just gonna create a new folder called
hasher which is a library in the just
base directory of my app so right then I
go into it
sure and you can see on my editor on the
right hand side here we have a new
directory which is called Hatcher and
which has two files one is called lip
dollar s and one is called cargo Tommo
now this is a pretty standard setup for
a rust project this is some boilerplate
that the rest code always adds we can
delete this in this case so we start
from a fresh empty rust library and this
is a boiler clay the cargo file cargo
files are like package.json for rust
just that it's donal it's not JSON and
here's where we're gonna have to add a
bit of oiler plate because rust was not
initially made to work with wisdoms so
we have to do a very few things to tell
the compiler hey you know we're actually
working with Waze I'm here and I'm gonna
I'm just gonna yeah this is what you
should do to just copy paste it in so
first thing is we tell the compiler hey
this is a special type of lip it's not
really important what that is at this
point and the second one is that we
define a dependency on the wasn't
binding project which we yeah which I
introduced earlier so I'm sorry for
doing all the rest will will soon stop
doing rest and then the second thing a
second kind of boilerplate I need to put
in my rust file is this allowing
experimental features for the rest
compiler which is also it's also it's
gonna go away at some point and it's
also not super important to know why
we're doing this but just yeah this is
allowing your scrote to features okay
let's start off the first thing we have
to do in our rust code is we have to
define an extern crate which is called
waz bind gen that means hey you know we
have this dependency please link it
against our source and then yeah right
we have to include some of the imports
some of the sources in reload this
basically imports a bunch of stuff from
wasn't bind Jim and now we can get
started just writing a rust function
like this is gonna be a very simple Russ
function I hope you can understand it so
it's basically saying hey we want this
I'm bound basically imported to
JavaScript and then we make a public
function hash and hash takes an input
which is a string this thing is
statically typed input I think like this
it's a string and it puts a string out
yes these two strings look different
once and the other string that is a very
long topic in short one is a pointer to
a string or a reference to a string the
other is an owned piece of memory if you
want to learn more about this please
talk to me afterwards it's not really
important for forgetting the core
concept and then what we're going to do
is we're not going to hash it right now
we're just going to return a four minute
thing when we do hashed and then our
input okay this is annoying here so
we're just gonna say hey I have this
template string please format it for me
to include input we're currently these
curly brackets are I hope that's
understandable
right so we define the function hash
returns the string takes the string
returns a string take formats the input
to include hashed and parentheses around
it that's a pretty simple function we're
going to do the action hashing later
because I I don't know how to how to
write a shot to algorithm so I'm just
gonna pull a library how do we build
this now so we use cargo again you can
use cargo built and then you have to
specify it from target which is horizon
32 known no I know it's it's so
confusing unknown unknown means these
fields are normally populated for
information for the rest compiler but
for class and Wiseman's just as amino
Lystra platforms or whatever so we just
don't fill them in now it's gonna build
oh and I'm relying on the confidence
Network to world create lists oh I made
a typo here unknown : nice no it works
now it's compiling all the appendices it
wasn't bind gen and shouldn't take too
long so I'm just gonna block on it here
right
now and give us all the time to breathe
breathe and taking all the new stuff and
this is generally gonna generate some
files now then I'm going to show you in
a second
cool it's done this is gonna not always
take that long because it caches the
intermediate population results of
course and so you can just do it again
and then it finishes really quickly
let's take a look at what was generated
so we refresh our tree again and there
we can see here it's Hargett folder was
generated and in there we have another
folder or a couple of photos and this
one's the most important one we have 32
unknown unknown and then there is
another one called debug in there and
here we have the file that we're
actually interested in that's kind of
like the only thing in here that we're
really interested in that's the raw wasm
file we can use wasm dump which is not a
cool utility to like take a look at the
file them up right and so what we could
do for examples we could disassemble it
and then we see all the instructions in
webassembly text format that's of course
a lot of stuff and then we can also look
at headers I mean if anyone of you
remember it's the webassembly text
format you know you have certain headers
for certain sections and so there's a
bit of memory and a lot of functions and
a lot code too so what we could do now
is we could assume the same thing that I
already mentioned in my other talk is
here it is so we could just fetch it and
include it here yeah this one we could
just fetch it and include it and use
bebés IMI's instantiate and then kind of
provide our own runtime for it which is
kind of boilerplate E and it's kind of
boring so how does wasn't bind and help
here well what wasn't bind Jen does is
we run it again on our wasn't file and
what it will do now it will generate two
additional files target wasn't so you -
unknown debug hash sure was an
and we can specify an out directory
which is it of course convenient I'm
gonna put it in the top-level directory
of the of the actual web app because
that's the sources that we're gonna use
to run web assembly and let's do that
cool it's done let's see what it
generated so now we have two new files
once called it's very you know at the
bottom ones called hash RJ as deal is
called hash sure BG Dogg Wazza and I
think hasha J's is really interesting
file so I want to take a look at it with
you what it does is it imports this kind
of wasn't file which is defined at the
bottom and then it defines a lot of
funky utility functions and one really
interesting utility function is for
example pastoralism and there it shows
that like it takes all this annoying
boilerplate stuff away from us by doing
some of the work that we would otherwise
have to do manually for example here you
pass it a string Arg is a string in this
case it encodes that string into a into
a byte array into the buffer and then
what it does is it allocates memory on
this kind of shirt heap that the web
assembly module uses and fills that
memory with this with these you know
unsigned integer with 8 bits so bytes
and what it returns is a pointer which
is just an index basically like just an
array index of the location of this new
string and the length of the string so
that's just a convenience function that
the mole to internally uses but it's
super nice because this is the thing
that you would have otherwise have had
to do if you were using welcome yourself
without using wasn't by general in order
to pass strings so there's a bunch of
more stuff here which is also just
utility functions in order to use get
what let what's called pass ring to
blossom and then there is getstring from
vaasam which is the same thing in
Reverse and then there's a function
called hash which as you would have
guessed it's not a coincidence hash is
there because we wrote a function hash
if we were a function hash to
we'll also be in there and there are a
couple of interesting things here let's
first take a look inside we do the whole
pointer thing where we pass a strength
was M and then get a pointer in length
back and then we set an argument and
then we call the hash function here and
then we get the return value like the
real return value which is the string
which is then again read out of the
JavaScript byte array and then we you
know yeah free and return the real
return value to our JavaScript code so
this is the function that your
javascript code if you were using is as
i'm gonna show in a couple of minutes
your javascript code will they call this
you can also see that it's exported
using an x-acto script six module export
definition and now i can see you you
know over drawing a browser simple
browser compatibility stuff it's not
it's not really simple with whoever
sembly es6 modules aren't really
implemented for web assembly yet so this
doesn't actually work it does work if
you use webpack though because web pack
has like their own custom shim so if
you're a web pack user good for you how
many of you are wiping you lose good for
you that's really good nice so a lot of
people have web pack users so this is
all you have to do and then just yeah
i'm not going to go into too much web
pack specific it's really easy from
there on the like if you go to the
wesson by engine page it has a set up
instructions specifically for web pack
what i'm gonna show you is how you can
use like the rest of you how can you use
this in your app without having to go to
web pack and then there's this option
here for wasn't binding on the left hand
side here it's called no modules which
means we're in a browser environment so
please don't do yes six modules but you
find the hash function in this case for
example on the on a on a on an object
that lives on the window global which is
how libraries used to work in the back
in the days so let's do this instead and
i think i'll have to visit a different
file and reload this one yeah so now you
can see it has an exports if you
in here and further down it then puts
that exports on the window and and so
you can basically use it like this and
there's another really cool thing and
it's brand-new and it's called another
cool flex called nodejs
the nodejs flag turns this whole thing
into a a nodejs definition so that you
can just just use modular exports so you
can require the thing pretty cool it
runs a node I think I my example is
gonna be doesn't that I my examples
gonna be in in in the browser though we
can try out runs in node afterwards I'm
pretty sure it I don't know does it
anyway once no it gets were missing this
port it might I'm a browser person I
don't really know about it but this is
really nice I thought let's do no
modules then cool so now we we have hash
it out yes and we have defined in our
root directory and I showed you what it
contains and now we want to get the
stuff that's in there right so we want
to go into our app yes and now we have
to do a little bit of extra magic again
so we do an important this global I show
you how we have a global window object
now that contains hash so we're just
going to do it was a equals was fine Jen
which is how we import our hash function
and then this is a bit annoying still
but people are working on it we call as
and bind Jen on the wisemen file that we
have in this case hash or bheegi bheegi
azam and that will asynchronously
initiate the whole last thing and fetch
it and load it in whatever so this thing
returns a promise in this case it works
because my button is also a
synchronously listening for user input
so this thing's got definitely gonna
finish before my user clicks on
calculate when you have an app that does
stuff that is supposed to run wasm
before like it like instantly
synchronously
you need to you know await this or do
promise and do then run my or something
like this in this case I'm just gonna
it's gonna be fine
I hope let's do a yeah it's finally do
some demo hash input value and now we
can see I hope that we have Oh hasn't
been Jen's not defined can anyone guess
why so the sorry that was pretty quick
the errors here there is wasn't binding
is not defined
do you have time also the problem is
that we did not put it in our HTML file
so half of Dolce s is a script that you
need to put in your in your includes or
just bundle it somehow and get it on
your window global now to run
I hope nice so we do have rust to
JavaScript communication now which is
cool but it's not a hash yet so now I
hope the even cooler stuff starts where
we just include a Russ module just like
that and compiler
2002 and run so what are we gonna use
we're gonna use a I just you know look
this up in advance of course we can use
a crate arrest module called chat to I I
think it's good I haven't used it before
but it should be sufficient for purposes
and I also looked it up it has a
convenience method called sha to digest
and we can actually use digest string
which takes a string and just pull out
the hash digests off off that string and
yeah that's just let's just copy paste
up
all right
so the problem here is we still need to
import shot too so I'm gonna do this the
right way I'm gonna first edit
dependency - a shot - this is how you do
dependency management in Ross it
shouldn't be very surprising to you if
you know package.json it is a very nice
change if you have ever done c++
dependency management and I think the
version is 0.7 so and in our library we
need to do the same thing as with Exim
crate wasn't binding we also need to
import chat - and I think that's it I
think we should be set we should be set
to use it
let's do cargo bill and see what happens
[Music]
compiling oh we get an error function
okay this is a I mean the era is pretty
good but it's just how to read it says
function or associated item not found in
chat - and it helpfully suggests this an
imported use so let's just use that
apart let's compile it
see that's how you use rust like you
just get compiler errors until it works
right so the thing is that you can't
like these curly like these curly
parenthesis mean that just output this
thing for it for like it would be a
string like and there's like certain
things can like implement this kind of
interface that string uses and we
actually want to output it as let's say
hex that's how you defined it yeah it
works nice it's always the best moment
in rustic Filippis life and now we have
the file on target again and we're going
to do a binding again and
run it on file and I think like
basically this should work without any
further modifications our Jaya site
because you know we just included it
nice and then we have the hash cool
amazing so that was it for the demo I
think we have written some rust and we
have included in rjs it was pretty easy
to use I hope it was a lot of setup but
I try to go through like the very like
each step individually I have a couple
more slice I think I have a bit more
time so a couple more features of wasn't
binding so we really just scratch the
surface in order to get you going with
it
it supports like structs like stateful
structures that you can use likes j/s
instances of like objects and you can
put stuff on it and it retains their
state through like even when it's rust
you can pass closures back and forth it
doesn't work in all cases but in most
cases it should work
you can import jsn like consulate lock
or whatever into your rust and then run
those and rust it has these opaque JS
value types which is the type that hides
the fact like the underlying whatever
this is from for us so that it's easier
to deal with and yeah as I mentioned it
supports required for nodejs although
people have not really I don't think
people believe me that it's working in
node so I might be wrong about this
there are a couple things that are still
very much working progress it is you
know passing around arrays and and
vectors is is a bit shaky I think it's
being worked on CC personal support is
in the progress source map debugging is
currently it works for some things like
I'm scripting which I'm not gonna go
into here but it doesn't work for wasn't
finding that we have here and as I
mentioned first class es6 module support
another thing that I really was quickly
want to mention is so will be really
cool if we could just use the diagram
uploaded to MPN instead of just you know
making a rust library in our JS project
and then funding that that right we've
let that rust library inside our own
small library and then exposing it to
J's we could just upload it to NPM and
then somebody could downloaded the
Darla's just as him as an NPN module and
that's exactly the idea behind wasn't
packed which was written by Ashley
Williams or which is still being written
by actually Williams because this is all
very work-in-progress you can install it
and you can use this to basically do the
same thing that I did with was a wood
carver built and was abandoned and one
set so you if you're in your rust source
file you can just use Waze and pack yeah
whereas in pack in it in this case and
it will you can see it below here it
will compile to wasm which might take a
while some i might not show it fully I
think it's doing some additional
optimizations which is why it takes a
bit more time so and then it will
basically generate the same files that I
already had in a package folder which
also has a package dot JSON and so if
you just go into that package folder
into NPM publish it's an NPM boom and
you have uploaded web sembly to NPM and
then somebody can use your library your
rust or C++ or whatever library from
JavaScript that's nice but still if you
want to use any random rust or whatever
library that doesn't have this publish
and yeah and PM you need to do this
thing that I just did where you wrap it
with your own kind of library right more
wasm on hack stuff Mozilla or all these
things are read out of like written out
much more purpose than ia just put it on
hex that mr. Orrick it's an amazing
series of blog post by like the people
who work on this web simulator org which
is an HTTP link which I just noticed
which is not nice I'm gonna correct that
rust wasn't get up that IO also has like
publishes these newsletters this week in
web simle I think and that's also a
really nice read to keep up to date with
a rapidly developing world of web
assembly and with that I say thank you
for listening
[Applause]
[Music]